i have strongly welcomed applications
made last month by sweden and finland to
join nato
we are now working
very actively on the next steps in the
accession process
you and i have been in close contact
these past weeks
and over the weekend we both we both
spoke
with president edward
the security concerns of all allies must
be taken into account as a part of the
nato accession process
turkey's concerns are legitimate and
must be addressed
no ally has suffered more at the hands
of terrorists than turkey including
grievous attacks by the terrorist group
pkk
we all agree we must redouble our
efforts in the fight against terrorism
that is why at the summit in madrid
i have convened a special session
devoted to nato's counterterrorism
efforts
and that is also why sweden and you
personally prime minister have taken
concrete steps in recent days
to directly address turkey's concerns
you have already amended swedish law
you have launched new police
investigations against the pkk
and you are currently looking at turkish
exhibitions requests
these concrete steps
represents a paradigm shift in sweden's
approach to terrorism in a more
dangerous and more unpredictable world
we are now working together on an
agreement between sweden
finland and our allied turkey
to further address security concerns
including
around arms exports and the fight
against terrorism
senior officials from turkey
finland and sweden have been meeting at
nato headquarters under my auspices
today
this is the second meeting in a week
i'm also grateful that president adorama
president tinasto and prime minister
anderson have accepted my invitation to
meet together in madrid tomorrow
that will be a further opportunity to
address turkey's concerns
and move forward with nato accession for
finland and sweden
finland and sweden's applications for
nato membership are historic
your membership will boost transatlantic
security as we face the biggest security
crisis since world war ii
all allies recognize this
all have made clear that nato's door
remains open and all allies know that
with you and finland as members
nato will be stronger
so once again thank you for coming thank
you for our meeting and pleased to have
the floor
thank you very much and thank you for
receiving me here at the nato
headquarters on the eve of the summit in
madrid
and it's by now has been four months
since russia launched an unprovoked
illegal and unjustifiable war against
its neighbor
the peaceful and democratic state of
ukraine
but russia has not beaten ukraine
but they hope that we will lose focus
they want the war of attrition
but i told president zielenski last
friday that our support for ukrainian
people should not and will not weaken
over time
because this war is not just a threat
against ukraine
russia's war has created a far more
dangerous reality for europe
including for sweden
and this existential threat to european
security order
will be there for a long time to come
and we must act accordingly
in sweden we're just in the middle of
the biggest build up of swedish defense
capabilities since the 50s
and sweden would reach 2 percent of gdp
as soon as practically possible and by
2028 at the latest
we are right now re-establishing
regiments reinforcing the island of
gotland
reactivating national military service
we are speeding up the defense equipment
procurements and strengthening our cyber
defense and intelligence capabilities
but we know that's not enough
building security requires cooperation
with others
and therefore we conducted a two-month
deliberation involving all parties of
our parliament
and in broad
majority we came to the conclusions that
the best way to protect protect sweden
and the swedish citizens
is not only to be a friend and a partner
but also an ally
in nato
and in may sweden applied for membership
hand in hand with our closest partner
finland
and with swindon sweden and finland as
nato members
the security of all nato countries will
be strengthened
because we will be security providers
within nato
and sweden would of course commit to the
washington treaty in its entirety as
well as to other nato doctrines
our application have received very broad
support from nato allies and sweden and
finland fulfills old criteria
but consensus with the nato is required
to take sweden and finland's
applications forward
our vulnerability to external threats is
increased until we formally become
members
and in response to this uncertainty
several allies including the united
states united kingdom germany france
spain norway and denmark have extended
sweden clear security assurances during
this period
for this we are very grateful
turkey has raised some questions
regarding sweden and finland's
applications
and our ambition is to come to an
understanding on the race issues
together with finland and nato
and i spoke with president aragon this
saturday and i would say it was a good
and constructive talk
and earlier today officials from sweden
finland and turkey met here in brussels
for new round of talks
and my strong hope is that this dialogue
can be successfully concluded in the
near future
ideally before the summit
this would make it possible to
immediately launch sweden's and finland
succession processes
and such an outcome would be good news
for sweden and finland but for nato and
the security of europe
let me make some things clear
as a member
sweden will contribute to the security
of nato as a whole including turkey
in a spirit of solidarity
we would embrace nato's 360 degree
approach to security
and as presented in my government's
extra foreign policy statement june 10th
sweden condemns terrorism in the
strongest possible terms
we are anika vocally committed to the
fight against terrorism in all its forms
and manifestations
and as allies we will be fully committed
to nato's nato counterterrorism policy
and take active parts in these efforts
our stance regarding pkk is crystal
clear it is less listed as a terror
organization in the european union and
is regarded as such in by sweden
during the last years we have several
times strengthened laws against funding
of terrorism
and sweden's terrorist legislation is
undergoing its biggest overhaul in 30
years
a new and tougher terrorist offenses act
enters into force the 1st of july
with the broaden scope and higher scales
of penalties
moreover
constitutional amendments are being
prepared which would have paved the way
for criminalization or participation in
terrorist organizations
there should be no doubt that sweden
will continue to stand firm alongside
other like-minded countries in the fight
against terrorism
our nato membership will have
implications with respect to export
control of defence materials to all nato
allies
alliance solidarity will be reflected
within our national regulatory framework
one of the issues raised by turkey
concerns sweden's response to turkey's
request for extraditions
these patterns are handled swiftly and
carefully by our legal system in
accordance with european convention on
extradition
sweden is not and will not be a safe
haven for terrorism